Now, we're almost done with implementing the car class, but if you have another
look at the drive method, remember, that we didn't update the gas in tank
theory variable. That computation is a little bit trickier. Let's first figure
it out on a sheet of paper. So, let's say we drive 100 miles. How much gas does
that take? Well, of course, that depends on the fuel efficiency. Let's assume
we have a car with great mileage. 50 miles per gallon. Well, then the gas
consumed is 100 miles divided by the fuel efficiency or 2 gallons. Right, 50
miles for one gallon, 50 miles for another gallon, for a total of the 100
miles. That's something that we can easily program in Java and here's the
formula. Let's put that into our code. Of course, that just tells us how much
gas was consumed during the drive. We still need to update the instance
variable. Let's do that. Here is it. We reduced gas in tank by the amount of
gas that was consumed. And we need to set this value here. For now, we'll just
use the value of 50 miles per gallon. We'll later see how we can make every car
have it's own fuel efficiency. Now, how do we know we did this right? This
would be good opportunity for a tester program, and that's what I want you to
do next. Write a tester that constructs a new car, fill the car with gas, drive
the car. Show the gas level, after the drive. And most importantly, print the
expected value. That's what makes a detestor. Go ahead and do that in the
coding environment, and then we'll compare notes.